[Music]
what's up guys michael here to talk
about dune the story is legendary
saturating pop culture in a way few
other tales ever have some of its
elements like the massive sand worms
have become sci-fi staples which seem to
pop up everywhere star wars also uh
borrowed from dune liberally in its
world and themes the book is renowned
for being dense leaving readers with
plenty to unpack but for all the
conversation around dune's ideas and
epic world building there's decidedly
less said about the actual narrative and
when people do get into the nitty-gritty
of the story they mostly talk about the
seemingly cliched lead character with
this seemingly cliched lone savior arc
but the truth is actually far more
complicated and far more interesting
rather than regurgitating worn out
tropes we'd argue that dune is actually
commenting on storytelling itself and
viewed this way it has a whole lot to
say about our own reality so seal up
them still suits and get ready for a
deep dive into dune of course spoilers
ahead for the entire dune extended
universe but before we get into it i
wanted to tell you guys about wisecracks
podcast uh they're like our videos but
they're audio formed and a lot longer
with a bunch of great hosts now if you
want to hear more about our favorite
movies from classics to recent releases
check out show me the meaning where host
austin ryan and raymond plus a bunch of
great guests uncover all the deeper
meaning hidden beneath the surface of
our cinematic favorites now for a
breakdown of everything going on in the
cultural zeitgeist we got culture binge
hosted by serbia and myself where we use
current events as an occasion to analyze
what's going on in our culture they're
both great i think you'll love them so
check them out wherever you listen to
podcasts subscribe to them on itunes or
spotify and also check out our wisecast
channel on youtube to get alerts about
live streams and watch video versions of
all of our podcasts now back to the show
to set the stage let's time travel back
to
the prestigious 1966 hugo awards for
sci-fi in which dune was voted best
novel interestingly that year's awards
ceremony included a one-time category
best all-time series many of those
nominees remain very culturally relevant
today and if we take best all time to
mean influence on the genre we can see
some clear sci-fi trends that were
percolating right when dune was born for
example most of these series look at the
formation of empires or dynasties like
barsoom where john carter turns a
nomadic drive of martians into a royal
dynasty and all of them unquestioningly
feature genetic essentialism i.e
eugenics as best embodied by lensmen's
genetically perfect space cops and they
all have protagonists that are
exceptional men single-handedly
triumphing over evil and being valorized
for their achievements like foundation's
harry selden with his unmatched genius
and visionary plan to preserve humanity
what this shows us is some foundational
tropes of the sci-fi genre tropes which
dune at first glance
seems to abide by as well to explain
let's get into a lore dump dunes galaxy
essentially runs on space feudalism
where upper class houses rule entire
planets at the best of the emperor who
rules the entire galaxy houses collect
the fruits of their planet's labor pass
it up to the emperor and they keep a
little for themselves for the trouble
while the emperor has the most power in
the galaxy there are also other
organizations throwing their weight
around much like the church in the era
of european feudalism dune has the beni
jesuit a quasi-religious sect of
seemingly mystical women the benny
jesuit are engaged in a ten thousand
year old selective breeding program that
essentially aims to create the ultimate
extra human they hold great but subtle
political influence throughout the
galaxy that includes supposedly
primitive planets where they've ceded
myths and legends about themselves you
know so they can potentially leverage
their power there in the future one of
these planets is arrakis where the
action of dune unfolds dune follows
paula tradies heir to one of the great
houses and trained in the mystical benny
jesuit ways by his mother his family is
ordered by the emperor to go rule over
the dangerous and barren arrakis which
happens to be the galaxy's only source
of spice a key resource the spice must
flow but this setup turns out to be a
trap and a different great house betrays
paul's family and takes over the planet
now paul finds himself essentially
living as an outlaw amongst the planet's
oppressed indigenous peoples the fremen
but paul's extra human abilities align
eerily well with the messiah myth from
the fremen religion i remember your
gomjabar
now you'll remember mine i can kill with
a word
and his word shall carry death eternal
to those who stand against the righteous
and as his abilities grow in potency
paul ends up leading the fremen as their
prophesized messiah rallying the fremen
around the future promise of a lush
safely inhabitable planet paul leads
them in a revolt against the house that
betrayed his family the book ends with
paul not only in charge of the fremen or
even just arrakis but the entire galaxy
[Music]
so people aren't exaggerating about dune
being complex that complexity doesn't
just come from the sci-fi of it all
either where those all-time best series
from before solidified many fundamental
tropes of the sci-fi genre dune's
actually doing something much more
complicated and it all comes down to
paul's character art see when he assumes
the role of messiah to the indigenous
peoples of arrakis he's not just
stumbling into this comfy place of hero
worship he knows about the messiah myth
he also knows that the beni jesserit his
mother's allies seeded it into freming
culture via low-key mind control when
paul finds himself a fugitive on a
foreign planet he's suddenly left
without authority or social power for
the first time in his life and in order
to gain some of that back he manipulates
the fremen into worshiping him the
sleeper has awakened if you're thinking
hey that's kind of messed up it's
because it is it's pretty
straightforwardly colonialism like when
the spanish and portuguese invaded south
america bringing christianity with them
at the time colonial's missionaries
supplanted christian myths over similar
existing indigenous myths they also
folded what existing beliefs they could
into the christian faith this is called
religious syncretism i.e the fusion of
two or more religious traditions the
missionaries continued to prime the
south american population to further
invest in those myths over time and the
missionaries that came after held an
ever increasing sway over the population
side note it's no coincidence that in
dune the beni jesuit that see the myths
are literally called the missionaria
anyway many of these real-life
missionaries are even held as saints now
like father subiarana a spanish
missionary in yoro honduras that
apparently did a miracle and made it
rain fish on the starving town turns out
a natural weather phenomenon makes it
literally rain fish in euro annually
which is a bonkers topic for another day
however father suburanus still gets the
credit via an annual town parade in dune
paula tradies employs the benny jesser
its colonial myths for his own purposes
to insert himself at the top of the
fremen society this directly reflects
the ways in which myths are used in the
real world often to elevate the few and
subjugate the many and dune's author
frank herbert isn't doing this by
accident the text is highly self-aware
paul's ascension to galactic dominance
isn't framed as the triumphant hero's
journey far from it by the end paul's
becoming cold uncaring and calculating
he's traded his ties to humanity in
order to gain extra human powers which
at this point include a full-blown
higher state of consciousness he can see
the entirety of time and he knows for a
fact that his actions will lead to a
horrific galactic crusade with billions
dying in his name this bums paul out but
apparently not enough to try to fix
things the deed is done and the blame
rests firmly on him throughout the story
he sees flashes of the upcoming carnage
but never takes sufficient action to
stop it this probably has something to
do with his childhood see paul's been
raised knowing that he was destined to
rule and to wield power over people all
of his schooling his training with
various experts was to prepare him for
this inevitability his entire life has
been defined by this and he has never
known any other perception of himself
you will make a formidable duke add his
benny gesserate mother to this
constantly telling him he's special and
destined for great things like the
ultimate helicopter parent of a
harvard-bound viola state champion who
also just solved cold fusion she told
him he was special and took every step
to make sure he'd live up to that
expectation the aristocracy whether by
feudalism or by the royal right to rule
we're told that they were the only
people who were capable of ruling they
perpetuated this myth into their
children and everybody else for that
matter we also see it in that particular
blend of western civilization's
colonialist racism this credo drove
people to believe that their country had
the obligation to teach supposedly
uncivilized countries how to behave we
continue to see echoes of this today in
the notion of american exceptionalism or
other western nation building you can
check out our recent rick and morty
video on the topic ultimately whether it
medieval or modern the purpose of these
stories is the same acquisition and
maintenance of power dune with its
houses and prophecies essentially clones
this ethos while adding a sci-fi flavor
we ourselves receive a slight problem
with in-house and trains
paul is defined by his sense of inherent
exceptionalism buttressed by his own
grandiose self-perception he's perfectly
comfortable misleading the fremen and
using them to take the galactic throne
paul experiences plenty of doubt
throughout dune but he never questions
his right to rule he is sculpted by the
systems of dune's universe and
especially by the stories that are used
to justify them in turn he sculpts the
universe with new stories of his own we
fremen have a saying
god created arrakis to train the
faithful
one cannot go against the word of god
it's in this interconnectivity this
blend of world building and narrative
that allows dune to criticize the tropes
of typical sci-fi instead of parodying
storylines from the past dune looked
critically at the foundation of the
genre and saw mirrors in real world
oppression once more it saw the way the
stories that justify these systems of
oppression also seep into the way we
conceptualize our future this duality is
infused throughout dune itself too if
you look at the individual details
dune's narrative and world buildings
seem to endorse colonialist aristocratic
and eugenical viewpoints but when we
view paul's internal downfall
holistically it becomes clear dune is
actually asking us to consider if the
victories won in early sci-fi stories
are really victories at all because
arguably earlier sci-fi engaged with
ideas less critically headier fare like
the future history series or foundation
were mostly operating from a place of
post-war idealism all stories of course
reflect their author's biases but these
series seem explicitly written to
perpetuate a certain worldview the
protagonists of these works are all
blown savior types confronting big
obstacles what's more they're commonly
the people who invented the solutions
and the only ones capable of instituting
them they see problems in the universe
and make changes to try and solve them
dune however depicts a universe where
all of the political social and
religious systems were created hundreds
or thousands of years ago the characters
are working within these systems not
trying to implement new ones as such
despite all the big sci-fi ideas dunes
universe and the systems that underpin
it are much closer to how our real world
functions systems like colonialism
imperialism and capitalism were
established long before any of us were
born we're raised within the confines of
these systems with all the resultant
biases and blind spots our perceptions
of the world are defined by these
systems in ways we can and can't change
fittingly herbert once said that his aim
with dune was to highlight the pitfalls
and blindly following a single
charismatic leader to that end he
explored the way stories work in our own
reality narratives have always been an
incredibly powerful way to communicate
ideas
we tell stories to ourselves to define
who we are
[Music]
and we tell stories from history to help
us avoid the mistakes of the past but
stories dune warns us can also be fueled
for destructive forces used to justify
and reinforce unfair power disparities
in this way while dune has been seen as
yet another installment of the sci-fi
tropes of its time it's more fair to
view it as an active critique rather
than a celebration of them however as
much as stories can hurt they can also
teach and inspire arrakis
will become the center of the universe
released into the chaos of the 2020s
we're primed to learn the right lessons
this time either way its message is
profound the stories we tell ourselves
have power even if we're not always
willing or ready to listen to what those
stories are really saying but what do
you guys think is dune an incisive
commentary on the dangers of charismatic
rulers lording over empires or does it
mostly parrot the same sci-fi tropes
that sought to critique let us know what
you think in the comments huge thanks to
our patrons for all your support and
don't forget to check out our podcast
hit that subscribe button like you're a
careening sand worm in the desert and
don't forget to ring that bell and as
always thanks for watching later
[Music]
so
[Music]